meagan Marco opens up for the very first
time about her romance with Prince Harry
I might want to compare
and set up the suit star covers the
October issue of Vanity Fair then reads
she's just wild about Harry inside Megan
breaks her silence about being thrown in
the spotlight when she started dating
her royal bow quote right out the gate
it was surprising the way things change
but I still have this support system all
around me and of course my boyfriend
support we're really good to see how
compatible they are Harry and Megan met
in London through a friend in July 2016
although the pair's year-long
relationship has come with backlash the
actress says she's able to tune it out
quote were two people who are really
happy and in love adding I'm still the
same person that I am and I've never
defined myself by my relationship the
two lovebirds have yet to make a public
appearance together but Megan says she
and the 32 year old royal are enjoying
their privacy as a couple she said quote
I'm sure there will be a time when we
will have to come forward and present
ourselves and have stories to tell but
we're happy personally I love a great
love story
[Music]
you